- [Instructor] In this
video, we're going to think
about the economic profit of a monopoly,
of a monopoly firm.
And to do that, we're gonna
draw our standard price
and quantity axes, so that's quantity,
and this is price.
And this is going to of
course be in dollars,
and we can first think about the demand
for this monopoly firm's product.
And the demand curve would look similar
to other demand curves that
we've seen multiple times,
that at a high price, people
wouldn't be demanding a lot,
and then at a lower price,
or as price goes lower,
people are going to demand a
higher and higher quantity,
or the market will demand a
higher, and higher quantity.
So that might be the demand curve.
Now what's interesting
about any imperfectly
competitive firm, and the
extreme case is a monopoly,
is what the marginal revenue curve
looks like given this demand curve.
In a perfectly competitive firm,
the marginal revenue curve
is equal to the demand curve,
and in that situation, it's
actually a horizontal line.
But here, because when the
monopoly firm reduces price,
it doesn't just reduce it
on that incremental unit,
it would be typical that
it would have to reduce
its price on all of the
units, and we've studied
this in other videos.
You have a marginal revenue curve
that would go down faster
than the demand curve,
it would look something like this,
and if this is unfamiliar to you,
I encourage you to watch
some of those videos
that go into depth why this is happening.
So it's a monopoly, or
actually any imperfectly
competitive firm, its
marginal revenue curve
will go down faster than the demand curve.
So what would be a rational quantity
for this firm to produce?
Well to think about that,
we have to think about
its marginal cost curve.
So its marginal cost
curve, the typical way
we often think about
it is, at first you get
some economies of scale,
but then you start having
coordination costs, and maybe
some diseconomies of scale,
your inputs start getting more expensive,
and so your marginal cost curve might look
something like that.
And the rational quantity produced is,
as long as your incremental
revenue for every unit
is higher than your incremental
cost for every unit,
you would wanna produce more,
and more, and more, and more
until the point that your marginal cost
is equal to your marginal revenue.
And so the rational quantity to produce
right over here would be right over there.
I'll do that Q, I could
call that Q for the firm,
I could also call that Q sub M,
because we're dealing with a situation
where the firm is, at least
from the producer side,
it is the market, it is the only producer,
it's a monopoly.
But what's the price here?
Well to know that, we just have to look
at the demand curve.
At this quantity, the
price is right over here.
So the price is right
over here, and once again,
we could call that the market price,
and so something interesting
has happened here
for the monopoly firm.
In a perfectly competitive
firm, where the marginal cost
and demand curves intersect,
that's what dictated
the demand, because the demand curve
and the marginal revenue
curve were the same.
But here, we are now producing
a quantity less than that,
we're producing a quantity where price
is greater than marginal cost,
you could see it right over there.
At this quantity price is
greater than marginal cost,
and so you can view this
difference right over here
as kind of a markup that is possible
for a monopoly firm to do
that would not be possible
with a perfectly competitive firm.
And this also introduces an idea
of dead weight loss.
Because at least in theory,
at a higher quantity,
people were willing to pay
more than the marginal cost,
so you would think that there is some type
of a benefit that the
market as a whole could gain
from that incremental unit,
or those incremental units,
and then even some more incremental units.
It feels like there's to
gain, but because of what
is rational for this monopoly firm,
and there's insurmountable
barriers for entry
for other people to enter, this
is not going to be captured
until you have this dead weight loss.
Now an interesting
question, and this is where
I started off is, well what would be
the economic profit
for this monopoly firm?
And to think about that, we have to think
about the average total cost curve.
And so the average total
cost, I'll draw a typical
average total cost curve, it
might look something like this.
While marginal cost is below
the average total cost,
the average total cost
will trend downwards,
and as soon as marginal cost is higher
than average total cost,
well now of course,
average total cost is going
to start trending upwards.
So marginal costs intersects
the average total cost curve
at the minimum point right over there.
And so based on this
average total cost curve,
it looks like this monopoly firm
is earning an economic profit,
because at that quantity,
this is the price
per unit it's getting.
This is the average cost per unit,
so on average per unit,
it's getting this height,
it's getting this
difference right over here,
and then if you were to multiply it
times the number of
units, well that's going
to give you its economic profit.
So you could view the economic profit
in this situation as
being this shaded area
of this rectangle.
So I'll leave ya there.
The big thing to appreciate is,
when we're dealing with
imperfect competition,
and the extreme form of a monopoly,
your marginal revenue curve is
no longer your demand curve,
and your marginal revenue
curve is downward sloping
like this, it's not the flat curve
that we saw with the perfect competition.
And because of that, your marginal cost
is going to intersect marginal revenue
at a quantity where price is
greater than marginal cost,
which introduces dead
weight loss in the market,
and the way to think
about the economic profit
is to compare what that
price in the market
is at that quantity, to
the average total cost
at that quantity.
And what's also interesting
about this monopoly firm
is because of the barriers to entry,
we talked about in the long
run with perfect competition,
if there's economic profit going on,
more entrants would enter into the market,
but that's not going
to happen in a monopoly
because the barriers to entry are so high.
So this monopoly is sitting pretty,
it's going to be able to keep earning
this type of economic profit,
unless something dramatically
changes in the market somehow.